[Music]
in please send nudes news oh yeah
depending depending send nudes and I'll
judge them okay from anyone No thank you
squirt I got bored with just naked they
gotta wear like a outfit like Mickey
Mouse or something speaking of snapchat
dude I mean no more dick pics and stuff
man it's like it's over now
snapchats done has done his diet it's
done
they're shutting it down it's like
pretty much there no cuz everyone's just
used to Esplin grabs yeah yeah but you
don't send nobody sends news and
instagrams see and Amir
you submitted by fan from submitted by
fan from Belgium do you get a bunch of
instruments I'm not saying anything cuz
every time I say some [ __ ] I hit a
[ __ ] flood of nasty [ __ ] I got it
Lochte well send them over to do that oh
no I don't want the dicks no no no no
they'll send me nothing for college
students traded their nudes for a puppy
oh wow that's all it takes just a puppy
that's supply and demand right there but
they get four separate nudes are they
hot are they girls they are girl okay so
they have a value down yes cuz dick
commodity is very low
yeah they're sent pennies the dollar the
exchange rate is terrible yeah it's
amazing that when you're a hot girl
you're your own currency like Nick is
like Zimbabwe currency and you can get
infinite amount you can get infinite
amount of money like you're putting your
own money yeah I'm a dick pic trillion
they're devout wave numbers in them
inflation yeah it's like make three of
dimes let's see that's what we did with
dipping we over inflated the marketplace
it's [ __ ] crazy look why did we do
that with so many dicks if we made dick
pics more rare they would slowly go up
in value over time you guys are just
incapable of it though I know yeah we do
to ourselves
yep but see you guys don't put tits
everywhere like Bitcoin there's no
nipples everywhere so this cliff looks
like Bitcoin like you buy one and the
whole
and then it slowly goes up over time and
now they're very valuable getting like a
good quality toothpick yeah mm-hmm yeah
so these for college freshmen from the
University of Texas at San Antonio they
they posted on Twitter like one of them
posted on Twitter of the screenshots of
the conversation so first of all this is
the puppy they got I would totally give
my balls for that dog but nobody was
they're not gonna give you a puppy for
it yeah they're gonna give you like like
a shake of pepper I'm gonna take
pictures of Jess
make it and send it for that dogs not to
not do one just one oh my bed yeah I
think I think she'll be okay oh yeah he
doesn't look a wreck so these four girls
got to share that puppy what did you do
it though for that puppy I mean if I
can't afford it I really really want
maybe how about this 600 bucks with a
puppy or your boobs see yeah see damn
girls print their own currency at $600
increments god damn that's good
was that a [ __ ] it's a husky hmm I like
husky puppies the conversation if I had
it if it was my dog I'd name him fluffy
that's didn't Tibby not white
yeah it's only appropriate it starts
with a guy asked me to pay him in nudes
for a baby husky should I do it and then
the roommate Maria says I'll send mine
in all caps
I think dope as girlfriend's by the way
yeah can't wait this end yeah that's a G
I bet you their fathers are so proud
right now yeah I was Maria that day what
does that mean what I mean Maria is the
girl that has like further contact photo
let's see it looks like she's sucking
dick true yeah that makes sense sure no
it looks like she's blowing it
we like Maria we like Maria try roomies
Trap House three four one five it's
probably a bong but we like Maria we do
like her yeah she's actually my favorite
no I'm not saying that it's right I'm
saying that it is right I'm saying that
it's probably that she's probably not
just a picture of her suckin dick in her
profile probably I thought she was just
warming up a [ __ ] tube for a science
experiment
yeah oh my god maybe she's blowing it to
a bottle making a sound yeah yeah
something cat says get the dog and then
they say oh my god send nude send nudes
Maria says in all caps oh my god wait
this girl sent me nudes we can use hers
instead of ours she even sent bids what
oh yes and Maria says don't ask how I
got them I think I was drunk to be
honest have you ever randomly sent your
girlfriend's nudes randomly no have you
ever sent your girlfriend's muse uh I
don't think so
have you ever seen your girlfriend's
name okay so this is not a comment yeah
I don't know yeah yeah I've seen their
friends nudes and their guys as usual
that came out of wingdings to me yeah
there's Jill again fill away and I will
have just dick pic don't don't barn
underneath the bus alright you're okay
okay Jill's friends okay and Bart's
friends but maybe I don't know I thought
they were close an apartment maybe it's
Gio but sometimes I would just want I
would see their snapchat or whatever it
is
oh there's a there's a set of balls
there what happened there does this
[ __ ] dick there what happened there
dude snapchat or is it a group text I
don't know it's I just don't know who it
is but it's there I forgot who was
sending it you guys don't know yeah they
do maybe if I heard names I don't want
to feed too much into it cuz our fans
are the pet
got it understood yeah the conversation
continues Maria says she's a [ __ ] it's
not me okay I swear cats like oh my god
I opened that with people behind me
Maria says I sent that with people
around the embrace of humane body Alison
says oh my god he probably thinks it's
me Maria says little did she know she
was talking to a Vanessa this ho is
about to get us some Huskies oh is that
the new thing people are talking about
finesse what is that like when they can
like somebody on again you know what's
interesting is after you send nudes to
this person now he's all horny and then
you go pick up the puppy isn't that just
a weird interaction thanks for the tip
so we get the dog first and then once
we've gotten like aren't sending it to
you now I wouldn't I wouldn't try and do
that I need to trade exactly i'ma wait
I'll wait for the air drop to come in
and back okay titties okay great I'm
gonna spank to this later so you need to
hurry up and take this dog Wow yep yeah
Maria says look what I just picked up oh
you should call him boobie oh that's a
good question the best ones pretty flash
yeah
flash is cool yeah so then Maria got all
kinds of backlash from everyone saying
like what the [ __ ] like does this grow
even know you sent her nudes out and
like you paid God it's pretty wrong they
posted it up like on Facebook or
something
Oh Twitter it's an attached her face
yeah this little face it doesn't matter
then who gives the absolute [ __ ] yes
nudes and Nikki everywhere in that case
because I put on all over the place
everyone see Nikki nude you just don't
know what as it should be kind of
respectful any minute thank you she
sweeps this out the caption says I asked
the girl for consent to use her nudes
y'all weirdos get out of my mentions
weirdos
yeah then so it's this girl says yes or
actually you want to read it
Maria says hey girl someone asked us for
nudes in exchange for a puppy ha ha can
I use the ones who sent me she's like
what some guy told me my roommate my
roommate that he'd give us a husky if we
sent him news but he does she doesn't
want to send hers but we want a pup help
us as to out
can you at least send the good one
laughing emoji yeah well yeah I got you
so she knows what the good ones are I
guess yeah and then the girl says okay
go for it
that's content that is consent legal
consent and I'm pretty sure like we
don't nothing as always if the face is
not in it you know nobody's gonna know
too hard that's what I'm saying only the
husband can tell or if there's like a
tattoo or something I always like a good
news like steve-o I like a good nude
where you can see a prominent flash as
well in it because they did the know
like it's in the mirror and that's the
face yeah yeah yeah I always like that
yeah snores a little bit dirty yeah
exactly
yeah for some reason it's possum why is
the mirror that always like the dirtiest
thing you've ever seen in your life ever
there's like they just brush their teeth
right next to their [ __ ] mirror
there's all the spots give it a couple
of feet okay Jesus always [ __ ]
flossing your teeth or there's like
lipstick on it [ __ ] yeah yeah how do
they get spots on the mirror that okay I
know the bathroom mirror I know that one
the one by the sink but what about the
wall mirror how do you think it's [ __ ]
on that yeah this one that's why you're
here it's like water spots and [ __ ] it's
weird cuz my mirror doesn't have that
and I have a room mirror it says it's a
it's a it's very interesting to me I'm
like close it's because he's our stoner
friends he's not smoking because the
statement is ridiculous but the bat is
serious it's the delivery that's right
it's a legitimate question good and then
and then later on he's gonna watch this
27 times and trying to find out where
the joke
story of his life he's always like I
don't know why you guys are laughing I
don't believe all laugh at the same time
that's why in a lot of people's minds
I'm actually a comedian I'm just living
homey but I don't need your titles I'm
just living yeah I'm just that's I'm
just being me [ __ ] so when you get
introduced to the show stand-up comic
Joe what the [ __ ] who's that like a
motivational speaker what leave girls
didn't have to send their own nudes
they've just sent some random girls knew
who was Hooper missed it yeah yeah well
damn problem friend I see you I better
not see the stories I mean movies are
made about these kind of girls in
college yeah yeah yeah yeah then they
get and they get caught for stereotyping
I'm like these girls exist then they are
yeah just like the douchebag guys are
real yeah they exist I mean there was a
huge I think it was a chlamydia epidemic
at one of the colleges that are going to
speak at they were telling us one of the
dorms just had so many you know people
being passed around that chlamydia got
passed around so what are they doing
they're like walking people walking
through in hazmat suits and [ __ ] what do
they do they just I think they everyone
had to be treated simultaneously he says
yeah it's like they put you in a big
plastic bubble and and they treat you in
there and then they have and they have
to go with you have to go in through a
chamber attached to a clean room like
this even [ __ ] et yeah yeah now Ashla
media by the way they still have media
ammonia Allen's horse down
[Music]